morning everyone it's
9:30 welcome to science technology and
2023 we have a fairly full agenda for
the day we're going to begin in just a
few minutes the public hearing on House
Bill
458 to which a non- Germain Amendment
will be proposed later and this public
hearing is on that non-gain
Amendment following the public hearing
we will have a brief five minute recess
and then at 10:00 we will begin an
executive session on 12 retained
bills and that EX executive session will
last as long as it needs to for us to
get through all 12
bills as is our usual custom we'll begin
this meeting by all rising and joining
with representative Doug Thomas as he
pledge
States and to the Republic for it stands
one
nation IND
all so before I officially convene the
public hearing I want to introduce the
newest member of science technology and
energy representative Steph Kennedy is
going to be joining us for the
next year on the committee he replaces
representative Troy mner who resigned
his seat in the house so I'd ask US
Representative Kennedy to introduce
himself briefly tell us where he's from
and a little bit about his background
representative Kennedy thanks Michael um
I'm representing Hudson District
13 uh I'm a retired scientist my uh my
area was chemical physics but I've
worked in many many different fields
which says something about my
personality but uh the last 15 years I
was working mostly in medicine so that's
the brief picture of who I represent in
my
background thank you uh representative
Kennedy since he does not know most of
us I'd like each of us to introduce
sbers thank you Mr chair um my name is
James Summers I represent Rockingham
District 20 that's uh plast out
Southampton and Newton and uh this is my
second non-concurrent term on this
committee and uh Al I've come from the
trade of was in the US Navy I was a n a
nuclear engineer and then um for the
last 20 years or so I've been a uh
network engineer and run my own network
engineering
company nice to meet
you my name is representative Lex bney
uh I represent Grafton District 11 and
developer hi I'm Chris muns I am a
representative from Rockham County
District 29 which is the town of Hampton
um this is my second non-concurrent term
as well um I spent most of my
professional career working in um in the
private sector and business um and um
spent um five years in the nonprofit
agency good morning and welcome aboard
uh I'm Mike Harrington I represent
straford district 18 this is my I don't
know sixth seventh term on this sixth
term maybe on this committee but they
were not concurrent because in the
middle there I was a pu commissioner and
before all the state stuff uh I'm a
nuclear engineer and I worked as a
supervisor at uh CBR nuclear plant for
years hi welcome Doug Thomas um
Rockingham County 16 which is comared as
just the town of Londoner um in my fifth
term uh previously I was US Air Force uh
uh Munitions maintenance area and also
worked for many many years at H Mar
Forest space in the acquisition program
management Logistics
World representative Michael Bose
Rockingham District 5 the town of eeping
chair of the eping planning board as
committee JD bernardy Rockingham
36 with Hampton Falls uh Kenington
Southampton Newton and
plastow uh background
biochemist uh Navy nuclear engineer
attorney and worked in pharmaceutical
development
I'm Janine nder your
seatmate I represent the town of marac
I'm uh this is my seventh term and our
late speaker dick hinch put me on this
committee five terms ago and I've been
since um John licki I represent uh Mason
Greenville and uh Brookline uh this is
my third non-consecutive term uh my
background is that uh mostly I have
worked in um industry startups uh doing
uh systems and electrical engineering
and um that's
it Henry Noel Coos 5 Berlin um I retired
from the city of Berlin as the
superintendent Tom Corman Grafton 15
which is Ward three of the city of
Lebanon uh I am a retired computer
science Professor from Dartmouth where I
taught for 29 and a half years I'm
co-author of the leading textbook on
computer algorithms I chaired the
computer science department for six
years at Dartmouth and also directed the
writing program for four years and this
is my first term in the
house Tom PL belnap one that's uh New
Hampton in Center Harbor um this is my
second uh term both with the stn uh the
background is U chemical research
analytical Sy synthesis uh in a chem
chemical research facility un Royal
chemicals welcome uh I'm uh Wendy Thomas
I represent the town of marac um I have
experien as a clinical microbiologist an
executive director of a nonprofit I've
worked in Energy Efficiency and I'm one
of the water Warriors in marac that's
fighting our past problem from St gain
thank
you okay thanks everyone for that quick
introduction and welcome once again to
Representative Steven Kennedy with that
I will open a public hearing on a non-
gerine amendment to House Bill
458 relative to reestablishing the
commission to study the assessing of
power
generation and I will recognize
representative Tom Corman to introduce
this amendment representative
Corman
thank you Mr chairman in 2022 HB 410 was
passed it became RSA 72 8-f establishing
the study Commission on the assessing of
power generation and utility
transmission by assessing we mean how to
assess these facilities for tax purposes
both state and Municipal HP 410
specified that the commission would
contain three house members at least one
from this committee and at least one
from Ways and Means along with one
Senator and six members from outside the
legislature the commission met for the
first time in July of 22 and quickly
determined that it would have its hands
full focusing on just assessing power
generation so it put off assessing how
to assess
transmission HB 410 specified that the
commission would disband on November 1st
of 2022 the commission had not quite
finished its work by then it's final
report filed on October
2722 recommended that a bill be filed to
continue the commission that bill was SB
225 from earlier this year it
reconstituted the commission with an end
date of November 1st of this year and it
also made changes to the membership one
member of the public was added to be
appointed by the governor making seven
non-legislative members that public
member was intended to be the honorable
patab bramy who had been chair of the
Commission in 22
per RSA
1449 the majority of the commission must
comprise legislators and so
sb225 specified six house members at
least one from this committee at least
one from Ways and Means and two senators
the house members appointed were two
from Ways and Means David rochfort and
Richard Ames and four from this
committee Tom PL Chris muns James
Summers and myself the reconstituted
commission met for the first time on
September 25th of this year giving it
just a little more than one month to
conclude its business and that was just
not enough time and moreover there was a
mixup occurring with uh patab bramy
chairing the commission at its first two
meetings but it turned out that
apparently he was not the governor's
appoint e Lisa Shapiro was uh so Senator
Tim Lang ended up chairing the
commission this non- gerain amendment to
HB 458 continues the commission with two
changes to
sb225 First is that the end date becomes
November 1st of 20
24 and the second is that the six house
members would be two from this committee
two from Ways and Means and two from
Municipal and County government we
wanted to reduce the number of St
members because this commission is not
about energy as much as it's about how
to assess taxes on power generators two
ways and means members make sense in
this context and also two municipal and
County government members make sense
because these facilities are paying
Municipal
Taxes
thank you representative Corman any
questions for representative Corman
amendment seeing none thank you for that
I'll next call on representative Pat
abrami to make some very brief comments
about continuing this study
commission welcome representative former
representam yes this this is this
commission has had quite a journey we
had very great success
several years ago with the uh taxing of
Municipal taxing of uh utility assets
and that that's in place now and we
solved the big problem a 40-year problem
with that then the the power generator
folks power generator folks approached
us there's 59 power generating
facilities in the state from the
smallest Dam to the to seber nuclear
power plant uh we formed a commission
last year as was said uh we we ran out
of time but we were making progress
everybody in that commission there's
three three other than legislators
there's three constituencies the the Min
palities are
represented the uh Power gener rator
people are gener are represented and the
assessing communities is represented and
the goal of this commission is very
specific we got to get all those three
groups to agree on a solution and that's
what we did with transmission we're
trying to do this again the bill that
came out this year to continue to
commission came out late and we were
only able to meet three times and not
enough time although all all those cons
constituencies felt that we're making
progress again and that we wanted to
find a way to Fast Track getting because
the error we made last time was we we
put the end date is November 1st of
23 so what this what this amendment does
is it does two basic things it extends
the date now to uh November 1st of 24
and it changes the as was mentioned it
changes the mix because some of the
Science and Tech folks said you know we
really don't know this assessing stuff
uh what I did in the inter room that
wasn't said was I met with I chatted
with uh representive tort uh the uh
chair of of Municipal I said can you
find me two two people who understand
something about Municipal taxing and he
got back to me after his flight to
Europe and he he's a pilot he came back
the next week to me and said yes I found
two good people that we will assign to
this commission so that's what I wanted
to add to what was said and uh I hope
you do uh pass this amendment so we can
proceed uh where where we left off the
goal is to with with you doing it this
way is that we this this will be voted
on in first week of January Senator Lang
said he will help us fast track it
through the Senate so that we can get
working as soon as we can thank
you thank you honorable Pat abami any
questions for Mr abrami representative
Wendy Thomas thank you Mr chair um and
you may not have the answer to this
because I'm not quite sure how you were
involved how much you were involved with
this amendment however on line 19 it
talks about confidential data
reporting can you explain what that
is well that's that's one of the issues
that we're going to be
addressing right
now um the assessing data that the
municipalities say they need to properly
assess these is not available to them
because of
confidentiality and that's one of the
issues that uh we we've been discussing
and we need to continue to discuss other
states do allow uh not just for
utilities but for any any other
properties and that's the stumbling
block we have how can we do it just for
utility uh for uh power generators to
open the allow them to share the
information now when they go to court
which a lot of these do wind up in court
guess what it's open you know all the
data is shared but again this is one of
the things we're talking about um
there's no resolution to it yet but
we're having very good again we have the
right people in the room to have this
conversation and we want to continue to
do that thank you thank
you representative PL has a question
thank you chair and thank you Mr Bari um
just a a housekeeping that the RSA and
in this amendment on line 25 it's the
speaker that will appoint the two and
just so we don't have another mixup as
you witness yourself uh if the speaker
the speaker will be appointing uh
represent
tur uh
yeah was your last sentence representing
appointing
who or uh Ways and Means will suggest to
and the speaker will appoint them we
need the speaker to appoint him and make
offal want to make sure that the the the
speaker does a point and his uh Deputy
is the one that that actually does the
appointing um and we will we will give
him a heads up as to our hope is that
all the all the people who are on the
commission now will be reappointed the
only uh the ways it means people I think
we have two that we will we will they
they are looking for names believe me
they they they they go to chairs and say
who do you have so we'll get the two
municipal ones that we that uh
representative turkot talked about uh
Ways and Means is fine with what they
have and then I think among the four
here uh I know several of you said you
you felt uncomfortable so U hopefully
you'll let you'll let um the chair know
if you're still interested on in being
on this Commission because they do reach
out to the chairs looking for for member
cities commissions okay thank
you any additional questions
representative Harrington
more of a clarification on the question
you your question on confidentiality a
lot of the since we have a competitive
power Market in New England the uh
generators don't publish how much they
generate and when so because this has to
do with what they bid in in the day
ahead in real-time markets as well as
the capacity markets of course for the
biggest one CBR uh all you have to do is
go to the NRC daily report and they'll
tell you exactly what they're putting
out every day but they still consider
the information confidential that's what
they're referring to and it turns out C
Brook has negotiated anyway at the end
it's a
negotiated thing so representative Wendy
Thomas um this is in response to that
that comment do you want me to wait
until we execute or anything I just um
so I I'm I'm a little hung up on this
conv if you have a question go ahead and
ask I don't have a question if it's just
a comment let's hold
it well it's a comment wrapped up in a
question I still don't understand the
confidentiality I mean if if and this is
addressed to representative Harrington
because of what you just just said um so
they're withholding that information
because they want a better price is that
the reason well it's it's considered
confidential because they're in a
competitive market and every day the
price I mean as we sit here right now
there's a day ahead price that was set
yesterday and there's a real-time price
that's set in real time those vary based
on how many people bid in at what price
so if someone for example is has a
maintenance outage and they're going to
reduce their power by 20% that will
change what they bid in and that may
push the price of the of the real-time
market up or down so those are facts
they don't want the public to know in
advance basically competitors it's not
so much they don't want you to know they
don't want the other generators to know
thank you okay thank you very much thank
you Mr chair all right there's one last
person who would like to speak to us
about this uh non- gerine Amendment
that's James Mahan here to representing
the New England power gener generators
Association Mr Mahan
thank you Mr chairman as you said I'm
Jim Maham with the DuPont group I'm here
today on behalf of the New England power
generators Association uh we've kind of
been the moving party on this for the
last couple years to try to get um um uh
support to address an ongoing problem um
kind of a post um devestator
restructuring issue um the uh new the
the power Jers in Hampshire as this
committee is well aware are not
regulated entities they operate just
like any other manufacturer uh the the
problem is that they're taxed twice
unlike every other manufacturer in the
State uh they pay a state utility
property tax and they also pay a local
um uh uh property tax uh what we're
trying to do here is um uh coordinate
and centralize that activity so first of
all there's not two valuations and
that's become a pretty conspicuous
problem where uh the valuation from the
state uh for an individual plant uh uh
might be half of or sometimes even more
dramatic than how the local entity uh
values it um so the first task at hand
uh is to address this Central issue of
whether or not
unregulated um uh manufacturers who are
not utilities should pay the utility
property tax the other issue is when it
comes to the local valuation what type
of agreed upon formula should be put
together so there's some consistency
Community to community with how the
power plants are
taxed which seems simple enough but when
you start unwinding things here for
example the because the utilities
because the um uh power plants pay the
utility property tax they don't pay the
Statewide property tax and this
essential question well maybe it would
be more efficient to uh move education
dollars from the um uh power plants
through the Statewide property tax as
opposed to making a um utility property
tax which goes goes into the um
education trust fund so I think that's
why uh this matter is the those
complications suggests that it may be uh
prudent to use the commission to sort
through some of these issues so that
when legislation is Advanced on these
two topics um there's kind of been that
deep work that's underway I should say
the other important party to this that
representative abrami didn't mention is
the Department of Revenue Administration
they are very involved in this uh
they've been a great resource um they
can produce more spreadsheets than you
can believe um but um they're part of
the team as well so but I'm happy to
answer any questions the committee might
have thank you Mr manahan any questions
Mahan seeing none I will thank you very
much for your participation and ask if
there is anyone else in attendance who
Amendment seeing none
I'm going to close this public hearing
on the non-gain amendment to House Bill
458 this committee will be in recess
until 10:00 at which time we will take
up an an executive session the 12
bills that we retained earlier this year
o'clock
let's take our seats everybody so we can
get
started
okay good morning and welcome to the
second part of the St meeting for
November 6th 2023 today from this point
on we'll be doing executive sessions on
12 retained
bills but before we start we'd like to
welcome to the committee for the day
representative Angela Brennan who was
here substituting for Ned red Ned R
rolds Who couldn't be with us today and
at our public hearing which started at
9:30 I introduced those of to the
members of the committee who were so
assembled at that time our newest member
representative Steph Kennedy who is
replacing representative Troy mner on
the committee representative Kennedy
introduced himself to the committee
earlier if you weren't here and you
would like to uh make a contact with him
and learn a little bit about him please
do so
later in the
day so with that we're going to begin
our business for the day and I'm going
to open an exec session on House Bill
159 and I'm going a represent recognize
motion thank you Mr chair I mve to
itl uh hb1 159 I recognize
representative Summers I second the
motion it's been moved and seconded that
we itl House Bill
159 now House Bill 159 was the subject
of a subcommittee which was led by
representative Bernardi so I'll ask him
to comment on the subcommittee's
activities thank you Mr chair yes uh the
subcommittee Met uh in the subcommittee
we agreed that it tailing the current
bill uh was was the right action and we
also had discussed that ideally we would
substitute a LSR which I had have in the
system which was uh going to uh direct
utilities to use laddering uh activities
or or purchasing purchase power
agreements that are not every six months
uh but at at uh broader or uh intervals
and and contracts that SP that that uh
were short medium long term in duration
um when the bill came back from uh OSS
to me uh it was not quite ready so I
have sent it back for further work and
since that time I've also received
comments
from uh representative Ms representative
McGee uh um Michael of ever Source uh
making suggestions so when it comes back
from LSR excuse me from OS again I
expect I may tweak it yet one more time
before it's finally signed off all that
being said is this amend and any
proposed amendment to this is not ready
for prime
time okay so we have a motion on the
floor of itl for House Bill 159 is there
discussion seeing none I'll ask a
representative Harington just one Qui
quick thing we shouldn't forget on this
bill is that an issue was raised that it
was unconstitutional which I agree it is
so we should always keep that in
mind okay further
comments seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the role on the question of itl
159 Doug
Thomas
yes Janine ner yes Michael
Harrington yes stevenh Kennedy yes John
licki yes Lex Brey yes JD bernardy yes
Tom PL yes James Summers yes C
McGee yes Rebecca
McWilliams
yes Jackie
cre
oh gone sorry uh Lucius parshall yes
Tony Kaplan yes Chris muns yes Henry
Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Corman
yes Angela Brenan
yes
19 to zero oh chairman Bose yes excuse
me now 19 to
Z okay by a vote of 19 to
zero we judge hb1 159 to be worthy of
itl and without objection I'd like to
place it on the consent
calendar without objection do you object
no without objection okay no objections
then House Bill 159 will go on to the
consent calendar and that ends the exact
session for house Bill
159 now we'll move on to an exact
session for House Bill 166 relative to
the I'd like to know who will write the
report uh representative Bernardi will
report HB 166 is relative to the
elimination of useful thermal energy
from renewable energy classes and I'd
like to recognize representative Thomas
for a motion thank you Mr chair I motion
itl
I recognize representative Berne I
second the itl motion on HB 166 it's
been moved and seconded that we itl
House Bill
166 representative Thomas do you have
any discussion of that
motion uh just that this has been done
many times and it just doesn't uh it's
not just not ready something that we
don't think it's a a good idea at this
time any further discussion on the of
itl for HB 166 representative Harrington
yeah I'm not going to give a long drawn
out speech here because I know this is
going to be passed as itl but people
should just remember useful thermal
energy has absolutely nothing to do with
the reducing the uh amount of
electricity that's used why electric
rate payers of spa of having to pay
higher electric bills so that some
entity can burn wood in their furnace is
beyond me it's just a total disconnect
we you know what's going to be next
we're going to put a rate payers and say
well you know I think this is a good
idea maybe we should have uh free milk
for everybody it's under four years old
so we're going to give them all free
milk and the rate payers will pay for it
this has nothing to do with electricity
it's just subsidizing people and
basically the reason it passes because
the people who sells wood chips have a
real good lobbyist so I think this is uh
and now of course we've got uh
government entities counties that have
gone out and taken advantage of this so
it's a program that once you start it
once you create the Beast it keeps
eating and it just keeps getting bigger
and bigger and regretfully that's what's
going to happen with this
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of itl on House Bill
166 Doug Thomas yes Janine ner yes
no uh Steven Kennedy yes
John licki yes Lex bery yes JD bernardy
yes Tom PL yes James Summers yes cat
McGee is this an itl motion itl
yes Rebecca McWilliams yes Jackie cre
yes Lucius parel
yes Tony Kaplan yes yes Chris muns yes
Henry
Noel
yes Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Corman yes
Angela Brennan yes chairman
Vose yes 19
to1 by a count of 19 to1 the committee
judges this bill to be worthy of
itl and represent representative Thomas
will be writing the report for the
Douglas Thomas calendar Doug Thomas that
is of course and um this will not go on
the consent calendar so this will be on
the regular
calendar and with that we'll close that
exec session and open the next exec
session which is HB
175 relative to the state's energy
consumption reduction goal
and on this bill I recognize
representative n for a motion thank you
Mr chairman I move itl I repres
recognize representative
CL I'll second that moved and seconded
that we itl HB 175 representative PL did
you have anything to say about this uh
thank you chair uh this um legis this
came up twice before it's been voted itl
um I believe the online polling were all
against it maybe 40 to zero so I
recommend we continue um not continue
this any further thank you
representative
Harrington yeah this was done at the
request of the Department of energy
asked me to put this bill in and I still
think it makes sense because if the uh
goal here is to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions that's more incomp thing than
saying fossil fuel consumption so you
could reduce fossil fuel consumption uh
and not necessarily uh there's other
things that you can do to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions that don't
involve fossil fuel so I think it's a
pretty good idea but I'm not going to
bother fighting it if no one else wants
it I guess I think the department of
energy seems to have lost their
enthusiasm for it so I'll be voting
discussion seeing none I ask a clerk to
call all the role on the question of itl
175 Doug
Thomas yes Janine ner yes Michael
Harrington yes Steven Kennedy yes John
lii yes Lex bery yes JD Bernard yes Tom
PL yes James Summers yes C McGee yes
Rebecca McWilliams yes
Jackie crean yes Lucius parshall yes
Tony Kaplan yes Chris muns yes Henry
Noel
yes Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Corman yes
20 so by a vote of 20 to nothing
HB 175 is judged to be worthy of itl
without objection we'll put this on the
consent
calendar hearing no objections it will
go on the consent calendar and
representative n will write the
committee
Report with that we'll close the
executive session on House Bill
175 and open an executive session on
House Bill 176 relative to rules of the
site evaluation committee and before I
entertain a motion on this bill I want
to relay a conversation I had with the
house clerk about the proper way to
motion a
bill that you plan to
amend the clerk tells me that the proper
motion
is I move to I move ought to pass as
and then the same person offers an
amendment so the motion would
be Mr chairman I move ought to pass as
amended on House Bill in this case 176
and offer amendment number and then the
amendment number so that's the proper
way to do this and with that I recognize
representative Harrington for a motion
motion that we uh approve uh HB 176 as
amended and um move the amendment number
is
223-229
H and I can speak to that if we have the
option I recognize representative lii I
second it's been moved and seconded that
we judge House Bill 176 to be ought to
pass as amended with Amendment 2023
H I recognize representative Harrington
to dis to discuss thanks this amendment
and tell us how it is different from the
original bill yeah this this kind of
goes back a long time there was a bill
pass dealing with the site evaluation
committee specifically having to do with
new requirements for win projects it put
in things like emergency plans and other
things that were is subscripted in law
and told the uh site evaluation
committee to rewrite the rules to
accommodate the new Bill well they did
that but they kept going and they
applied the sections that only apply to
win projects to all energy projects
transmission projects new types of
generation whatever it was they applied
it to it and that was a beyond what the
law authorized them to do so the
original bill that came out basically
said uh here's the here's the areas
where you overstepped your Authority
specifically but you also ought to check
all the rest of you rules to make sure
they comply with the law it was
discussed and thought that was too broad
so what the amendment does is it just
narrows it down to the specific sections
where the law was not uh followed and it
says fix your rules to match the law and
only in these sections that are listed
in the new Amendment and not a general
rules okay uh representative McGee so I
have a question representative
Harrington um can you can you um since
we're just you know we just received the
amendment recently we've looked at it
we've looked uh online at the statute
but can you just explain for us here
what changes will result from these not
not in a general way that they'll be
able to make their own rules but what
does this order them to do in terms of
changing the statute as far as that goes
there is no change what it does is it
limits them to specifically what was
listed in the original bill but it takes
out the look at all you rules as well so
specifically it talks about
um uh it it's the site rule which exes
the authority of the committee by
requiring the committee to conduct it ad
judic of hearing prior to exempting an
applicant from approval and certificate
provisions of 162 H and then there's
another rule that says requires the
proposed energy facility to include a
visual impact such impact is required
for wind energy systems only under RSA
blah blah blah there is no such
requirement RSA
16287 which applies to all energy
facilities and then the last one goes on
that's then two more goes on to say that
require all energy facilities to have a
sound assessment and fire protection
plan which required only for and wind
energy facilities under the law and High
Press gas pipelines under another
section of the law and finally it
requires all energy facilities to have
an emergency response plan there is no
such requirement in 1628 so basically
what it does is it tells the site
evaluation committee that well we really
don't are ruling on whether these ideas
are good or bad or should be in place or
shouldn't be in place the fact is the
law doesn't authorize you to do it so it
says follow the law as simple as
that you have a follow-up representative
McGee yes I I think you know this is
kind of illustrative of what the issue
is with having a late breaking Amendment
on a bill that has been batted around on
both sides of the house and uh on in
with multiple Vehicles right this was a
bill that was identified as it l or
interim study early on and we hadn't
really paid much attention to and now uh
the the way I look at it um we're saying
that that the site evaluation committee
is not able to undertake any um any
inputs in their adjudicative proceedings
that are not spelled out in the law um
but I don't see how this improves what
we have done and I think it needs more
gestation Within this committee so that
we have an understanding of what we're
asking them to do rather than again
having this come at this late time so
I'm not in favor of passing this because
there was ample time to present such
amendments during the SEC hearings that
we had on other with other vehicles this
year representative Arrington yeah just
again so we're clear this is the only
thing that was changed in the bill from
as introduced the as introduced bill in
paragraph 2 said in order to amend the
rules pursuant to section one of this
act the committee shall include but not
be limited to the following that but not
be limited to has been removed so
there's nothing news coming in here this
is exactly the same as it was when it
was introduced whenever it was last year
um the only thing we did was We Shrunk
down the scope of the bill to
specifically talk about the things where
they the site evaluation committee
exceeded their Authority and they simply
don't create law they Implement law and
if there's a requirement that says wi
facilities must have an emergency
response plan but there's no requirement
for any other type of facility to have
it the site evaluation committee
shouldn't be imposing that because they
think it's a good idea if they think
it's a good idea they can come back to
this committee and propose legislation
and we can put that in but they don't
have the authority to to to in install
these things on their own and in fact if
it went to the site evaluation committee
and they required them to do that I'm
sure some developer would take them to
court and win because is saying you're
acting outside of your Authority there's
no law that gives you the authority to
require this and all this does is say
make the rules comply with the law
period and that's nothing's changed
since it was originally introduced all
it's done is limit the scope down to
saying we got rid of uh include but not
it so Jael car probably should have
picked this up when they originally
reviewed the site evaluation committee
rules but somehow they they missed it
didn't realize that go ahead rep I I
talked to a senator who's actually no
longer a senator at the time who was on
Jael car I was not on this committee nor
was I on the site evaluation committee
at the time and I brought this to his
attention he basically said we've been
screwing around with those rules for so
long no one understands them anyways
we're going to pass them as is just to
get them off of our desk and that's what
happened so they blew it and they didn't
want to address the
issue represent pres ative
bernardy thank you Mr chairman I do
recall when we had our public hearing on
this bill we uh we specifically
identified or these four items were
specifically identified as problems and
hence I I think this amendment is is in
order it it doesn't make sense for us to
kick this can down the road any further
let's just fix
this further discussion representative
Ms thank you Mr chair
um looking looking at this amendment and
when I compared it to the original bill
I I see the same reference to uh
rules um but I think there may be a
drafting era um if you look at line 18
and it references um uh regulation site
301.8c
1 and three it the way it's worded it it
suggests that those that that rule that
those rules require all energy
facilities but if you actually read the
the rule it specifically says that those
rules relate only to high pressure gas
pipelines so um you know that being the
case I mean I think this is the way it's
worded is is an error
um so that that is a um I I I think
that's just a drafting error um and on a
more substantive note um if you look at
uh line 16 it says there is no
requirement in
RSA 162
H7 to permit visual impact assessments
well there is no some there is nothing
that specifically says that they can do
visual impact assessment but RSA 162 287
provides broad Authority for the site uh
evaluation committee to regulate quote
any aspect of the construction or
operation of a facility and the impact
on the environment so that to me would
give them the authority if they felt the
need to look at a visual impact
assessment so um I don't think that I
don't think you know paragraph B is
necessary because of what I just said
and as I said paragraph C I think think
is just out andout incorrect in terms of
regulation any further discussion
representative McGee and just kind of
put a pin on that note uh that
representative muns just made what this
brings to mind is the fact that we're
saying that the SEC should not have any
Authority beyond what we have spelled
out uh in the
statute how ever they are the body that
we've assigned to do site
evaluation um and so uh the general
Authority that's being pulled back I
think it needs more work more discussion
and not to be something that we are um
pushing through at the last minute
assuming that it's going to fix problems
with the SEC I think we have to have
more fullsome discussions around what
those problems are that we're trying to
solve rather than just shoving some
language in at the last moment that
again we have questions about and we
this was not a vehicle that we were um
that we were working on uh throughout
this period in terms of a retained Bill
status so um I really don't see any
reason to change the status that we had
um for this
bill so representative McGee you keep
talking about last minute
language uh thrown our way this bill was
produced last February so this language
has been around since then with the
exception of the three or four words
that this amendment removes from the
original statute so is that's a
mischaracterization to say that this Mr
chairman but in all of our meetings this
bill was itl Andor interim study so
there was no consideration of this bill
moving forward until this
week further discussion representative
Kaplan yeah just speaking to this
amendment and I I appreciate uh
representative Harrington's desire to
you know set things in order in terms of
the rules governing the the site
evaluation committee but you know given
what he just said about the way they
operate um I I am concerned that this
would have unintended consequences for
instance just an just the requirement of
having an emergency response plan okay
maybe that only by law uh is required of
certain facilities but and to my mind it
seems like a good idea for all
facilities to have an emergency response
plan as it would for any organization so
are we then saying that it's not
necessary to have an emergency response
plan if we say you know if we if we pass
this amendment so uh that's just one
confusion I think needs to be straighten
out so I agree with representative McGee
we need more time to think about and
hear maybe hear from other experts who
would be able to Enlighten us about
about
that further discussion representative
Bernard
already Yes uh this conversation I guess
uh ticks one one of the fundamental
premises of of how government is
supposed to operate uh New Hampshire
Constitution provides that the state
legislature make laws we set the
policies by making those laws we do not
give administrative agencies the
authority to make law make decisions
that are contrary or above and beyond
the policy prerogatives that we give
them
and so therefore you know I I find the
comments of Representative muns and
Kaplan not in order this bill basically
says this legislature is defining where
the agency is to act and how they're to
act and they need to implement that
policy
additional
comments representative Ms thank you Mr
chair I'd like to uh thank
representative Camp Kaplan for
highlighting um the um the language in
lines 21 and 22 because again that's a
drafting error if you read
C4 it says and I'm quoting an
explanation of why the setbacks
described by the applicant in response
to three above are adequate to protect
the public from risks associated with
the operation of high-pressure gas
pipelines has nothing to do with
emergency response
plans um Mr chairman if I may please
representative Harrington uh the you
correct there's a mistake in the
drafting so I suggest we just uh itl
this and I'll get those fixed and bring
them back next year I don't see there
going to be any crisis if we don't but
there's there's mistakes here must have
been transposing it from the last bill
bill or something on this because this
bill has come up before and so but it's
as written it's it has mistakes so no
okay so fast uh late breaking what do
they call it on on TV breaking
news it appears that uh that we now want
to back away from this uh Amendment and
this otpa motion so um that drafting
errors or other errors that have been
recognized can be addressed
further
discussion well because we have a motion
on the floor we have to vote on it even
though we probably want to back away
from it at this point so I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of
otpa with Amendment 2299 h a question Mr
chairman uh could I representative
Harington could I simply withdraw the
amendment is that possible that we have
yes you could withdraw the amendment
okay I withdraw the amendment then with
you you would also have to withdraw the
motion of ought to pass and withdraw the
motion of ought to pass okay the motion
of otpa has been withdrawn by R
representative
Harrington representative Harrington do
you have an alternative motion to
make uh move itl as originally
written representative uh Summers I
second the motion move and seconded that
discussion seeing none I ask the clerk
to call the role on the question of itl
for
time
Doug
Thomas yes Janine ner yes Michael
Harrington yes Steven Kennedy yes John
lewicki yes Lex pery yes JD bernardy yes
Tom PL yes James Summers yes C mgee yes
Rebecca McWilliams yes Jackie crean yes
Lucius parshall yes Tony Kaplan yes
Chris
muns yes Henry Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes
indeed Thomas Corman
yes uh Angela Brennan yes
chairman Vose yes 20
Z okay by a vote of 20 to
nothing HB 176 is judged to
be
itl and without objection we can put
calendar no objections registered so we
will put that on the consent calendar
and representative Harrington will write
okay with that we'll close the exec
session on HB
176 and now we'll open an exec session
on HB 381 relative to the system
benefits charge and I recognize
representative Thomas for an
motion thank you Mr chair I motion itl
n moved and seconded that we itl House
Bill 381 relative to the system benefits
charge representative Doug Thomas do you
want to say anything about
this
motion now I will defer to the
original U drafter of it this uh we just
don't need think we don't think it's
needed and so why vote for it this will
bill would
undo House Bill 549 from last year and
and I don't think that's a path we want
to go down at this point point in time
is there any other discussion needed for
this motion of itl on HB
381 representative Thomas yeah thank you
m Dr Thomas yeah I just want to add I'm
the taller ones thank you um I just
wanted to say that yes I agree a lot of
work was done on on the previous bill
that the chair mentioned this bill would
just undo it and there's no no need for
that when we made so much progress
discussion seeing none I ask the clerk
to call the role on the question of itl
381 Doug Thomas yes Janine nder yes
Michael Harrington
no Steven Kennedy
yes John lewicki yes Lex Bry yes
jie bernardy yes Tom PL
yes James Summers yes Cam McGee yes
Rebecca MCM Williams yes Jackie crean
yes Lucius parshall yes Tony Kaplan yes
Chris muns yes Henry noell yes Wendy
Thomas yes Thomas Corman yes Angela
Brennan yes chairman Vos yes
one the committee adopts the motion of
381 we could consider putting this on
the consent calendar unless there's an
objection representative Harrington
there is okay so this will not go on the
consent calendar and the itl
motion was made by representative Thomas
so he will write the committee report
for House Bill
381 so we'll close that executive
session now we'll open a new executive
session on House Bill 458 relative to
participation in net energy metering by
small hydroelectric generators and I
will Rec rep recognize representative PL
for a
motion thank you than you chair I move
that we ought to pass amended House Bill
458 uh with the amendment
2347 H representative Corman has
presented and introduced this amendment
earlier today which keeps the
six representatives in the committee in
okay hang on a second I'm going to rep
recognize representative Corman
first I second okay it's been moved and
seconded that we
adopt House Bill 458 as amended with
Amendment
22 2023 2347 H now representative PL PL
you can tell us why you think we should
adopt this uh I apologize for the
continuation uh yes now that we have all
committee members here I want to bring
bring them up to date that it was
introduced and now instead of having
um the speaker chooses
six Representatives one from St and one
from ways and means it is now still six
it will be two this amendment makes it
two from Ways and Means two from St and
two from
Municipal thank
you okay so the on the floor then is to
adopt this non-gain
amendment which amends the title of the
bill by changing it to reestablishing
the commission to study the assessing of
power
generation and those of you who are who
were at the public hearing earlier this
morning fully understand the reason for
adopting this bill to extend the life of
this commission through November 1st of
2024 is any further discussion needed
representative muns thank you Mr chair
um I I support um adoption of this bill
the only thing that I would um add or or
encourage is that um if we adopt this
bill and it gets adopted by the house
that every effort is made to expedite um
review and approval of the bill by the
Senate so that the commission can begin
meeting as expeditiously as possible um
what the reason we we actually need this
bill is that the prior Bill wasn't
handled as quickly as possible and so
the commission didn't meet until
September and um the commission really
wants to get on with its business and
and and meet as early as possible in the
year so anything we can do to expedite
that would be much
appreciated so noted representative
Wendy Thomas and how would one go about
Expediting that
as chair of this committee I would
consult with representative of Senator
ten Tim Lang who was chair of way and
means in the Senate okay and let him
know that when the bill gets to the
Senate he needs
to move it through as quickly as
possible he was the chair of this
commission last year so he he's well
aware of the issues okay thank you any
needed seeing none I would ask the clerk
to call the role on the question of
ought to pass as amended with Amendment
2347 H House Bill
458 Doug Thomas yes Janine nder yes
Michael Harrington yes Steven Kennedy
yes John lewicki yes Lex bney yes JD
bernardy yes Tom PL yes James Summers
yes C McGee yes Rebecca McWilliams yep
Jackie crean yes Lucius parshall yes
Tony Kaplan yes Chris muns yes Henry
Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Corman
yes Angela Brennan yes chairman Vose
yes 20
Z by a vote of 20 to nothing the
committee adopts the motion of aop pass
as amend
on House Bill
458 if we put this on the consent
calendar it will get through the house
more quickly therefore it can get to the
Senate more quickly so I recommend that
we without objection we put this on the
consent
calendar agreed seeing no
objections so
moved and representative plog will write
the committee report
Corman all right so now we'll close that
exec session and move to a new exec
session on House Bill 509 relative to
phasing out or the phasing out of the
minimal minimum electric renewable
portfolio standard and I'll recognize
representative Harrington for a
motion um I move uh to
pass all right I move for inum
study okay uh representative bne I
second that it's been moved and seconded
that we recommend House Bill 509 for
interim study is there any uh discussion
motion representative Corman thank you
Mr chairman as I am a new member of the
House I'd like to know what the
implications of moving a built to
interim study
recommendation from the
committee in the second year of the
house for a bill that the committee
judges to be Unworthy of Passage at the
moment but that could be potentially
recommended for passage in the future so
once a bill goes into the status of
recommended for interim study the
committee can then decide whether it
wants to actually study it further and
recommend it for future
legislation or not recommended for
future legislation those are the two
motions that will the bill will be
required be subject to later in the
session or later in the year so
referring the bill for interim study is
just a way to allow it to
continue but prevents its passage in the
session thank
needed seeing none I'll ask the clerk he
Hey Hey My My Hand was up sorry I'm
sorry I didn't see it representative
Wendy Thomas um just um some
clarification on on the interm study you
you actually answered part of my
question um by um the the previous
answer is it uh done by a subcommittee
or is it done by the entire committee an
interim study the entire committee will
have to once the pill is is passed as
inter interim study we'll have to decide
we'll have to decide at a future date do
we want to study this bill or not and
that'll just be by a vote of the
committee okay
thanks further discussion additional
questions seeing none I ask the clerk to
call the role on the question of refer
for interim study on Bill
509 Doug Thomas yes Janine nter yes
Michael
Harrington yes Stephen Kennedy yes John
lewicki yes Lex Bry yes JD Bernardi yes
Tom
PL yes James Summers yes C McGee
yes Rebecca McWilliams yes Jackie crean
yes Lucius parel yes Tony Kaplan yes
Chris muns yes Henry Noel
yes Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Corman yes
Angela Brandon yes chairman Vos yes 20
Z by a vote of 20 to nothing the
committee adopts the motion of interim
study
on House Bill 509 I'm not sure if we
need a committee report for interim
study that's TBD if we do uh I will
write it myself how's that
representative Harrington sure I don't
think we do okay whatever
consent if it goes onto the calendar it
will go onto the calendar and cons on
consent but I'm not sure it goes onto
the calendar I think it may still just
reside with our committee but I'll have
all right so let's close the exec
session on House Bill 509 and now move
on to an exec session for House Bill
558 dfn relative to Electric micro grids
and electric grid resiliency and I'll
recognize representative Thomas for a
motion
motion uh I
motion we
adopt
558 with the
amendment 2023
H representative N I second the motion
Mr chairman it's moved and seconded the
motion of ought to pass as amended with
Amendment
2321 H representative Thomas chair to
sub committee on this bill so tell us
what your subcommittee decided yes Mr
chair yes it was a good study committee
where we discussed the merits of
rearranging what the original bill was
going to have into uh basically a study
committee for doe to discuss the um the
merits of you know uh micro grids and
all the details that would be involved
with that uh it was a good discussion we
had a it was a 40 recom Commendation
from the subcommittee to recommend
adoption uh with the motion that I just
proceed okay any discussion uh
on the amendment 2
321h to House Bill
558 representative
Ms thank you Mr chair um I I I just have
a a couple questions um
relating to the language in lines 19 and
20 um and I'll just read it for the
record evaluation criteria and approval
process for utilities to propose a
limited number of microid grid pilot
projects to the Public Utilities
Commission annually so my questions are
there's two two questions really and
hopefully somebody from the subcommittee
can
answer um this language the way I read
it it it it kind of implies that um that
utilities are going to be the ones that
are going to be proposing microid grid
projects and my understanding was that
we were looking for private developers
to um developers or municipalities to um
uh propose microgrid projects so my
question is is this going to is this
limiting the ability of non- utilities
to propose propos projects and then the
second question is it talks about um
proposing pilot projects
annually and um that just seems odd that
you would be proposing pilot projects
annually you do a pilot to kind of do a
proof of concept and then you move
Beyond a pilot to real project so I just
was kind of curious what the logic was
for including that l language that that
word
annually well it was my impression that
this was in there as an option for the
study committee to
discuss uh those just one of the items
that that would be brought under
discussion I don't think there was any
intention to say that you would or or or
or that you wouldn't I would have to um
ask the other subcommittee members if
that was yourison as
well anybody else want to make a
comment
representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman yeah I just was looking back at
my notes from the hearing uh where we
discuss some changes that representative
Ammon might consider in the amendment
that we have before us and um we had
discussed um instructions to the doe
regarding um reporting on federal monies
and um discussing the value of microG
grids so basically basically uh giving
us information about what they're
finding from their
review um and uh let's
see we also discussed including the US
doe definition of a micro grid because
we didn't have that information in
statute and there was a question what is
a micro Grid in that hearing so I'm just
wondering whether any of those notes
that came from the hearing got
incorporated or uh were discussed but
then uh decided not to be included in
the
amendment yeah I it's um we
did talk about some of those ideas and
at the time we we felt with um we wanted
to get this study going and uh time
being what it was we felt that the that
the amendment that was presented to us
although not perfect was good enough to
to go through and I think we had some uh
discussion with the doe involving the
pilot programs and there ideas were that
they they really wanted to work out the
Technologies before they entered into
into any pilot program at at the time so
this is why some of that is still in
there is as being discussed um and
that's why we felt that in the in the
interest of this important project to
get going the amendment as presented was
was enough to get us through and
anything that has to be tweaked
obviously could be done at a later date
but um but yes those ideas were talked
about uh there there were many of them
but that's what the study committee is
for is to discuss these things thank you
that's fair and line 16 representative
McGee of the amendment says that
definitions and Technical requirements
to qualify as a microgrid is part of the
Department's investigative
proceeding
in
general a bill that requires the doe to
open an investigative
proceeding can provide guidance but it's
to touch on every single thing that an
investigative proceeding might
reveal so I think that um nitpicking the
language on line 16
through 20 through 30 would probably not
serve us well representative
bney thank you Mr chairman I'll just
point out the last one says any other
relevant issue raised in the
Department's investigation proceeding so
it basically covers
anything that is
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
of ought to pass as amended excuse me
chair representative Noel uh thank you
Mr chairman um I'm still wondering about
representative ms's first question about
the
utilities uh be leading the
process uh again being deregulated and
not responsible for for for generating
power anymore uh I'm curious how the
utilities get to be the ones who who
decide
that well I think that's a a good
question and it's something that the
investigative proceeding will explore
about so we'll just have to see what the
investigating Pro in investigative
proceeding reveals about whether it
else representative PL uh thank you CH
not the belabor this any longer but um
the line 16 along with 19 if I remember
right when I
attended uh the subcommittee and these
micro grids are going to be
interconnected with the utilities the
utilities be working with the mun
municipals and
businesses they're from the way I read8
line
18 you know once they get that if it's
can advance or not they will do that
reporting um and propose it I don't read
it myself s because of line 16 that
they're just proposing their own they're
still working with the municipals um and
businesses since they're going to be
tied into the utilities grid also it's
not a
standalone thank you representative
Wendy Thomas thank you Mr chair um this
is just a general comment about the
format of this bill um on lines 22 24 26
and
28 um and Oxford Comm is used and um I
had a big discussion with the clerk
about Oxford commas and he said oh no
they're not used in New Hampshire um
which is why because I said the name of
our committee should be science comma
technology comma and energy anyway it's
a minor knit however I would like to
know if you are aware of a state of New
anywhere I've never seen one there must
be one in LS though I would guess I'll
check and I will get back to you or to
everybody any further
discussion representative
Ms thank you Mr chair
um I
um I I'm I'm you know I I I heard a lot
of the discussion about you know uh the
way the language being drafted giving
the department the flexibility to to
look into to various things and um I
guess I'm I'm willing to concede that um
but I also uh am reminded of uh a
comment that one member of our committee
made um and on the discussion about a
previous bill that you know the
legislature um kind of sets the policy
and
tells everyone what to do um so um you
know it language matters um and you know
I just would have been more comfortable
if we' been a little bit more specific
with the direction that we're providing
to the um to the Department of energy
but um I trust that they will um you
know take as an expansive view of this
possible representative McGee I'll just
add by way of easing people's concerns
that I think in the first section um
starting on line 8 uh within 120 days of
effective date the department shall
initiate a proceeding to investigate
potential benefits risks and key
considerations around developing a
framework for electricity grids in the
state in doing so the department shall
consult with electric distribution
utilities micro grid technology
companies distributed generation project
developers high density load businesses
municipalities one or more state
universities and other relevant entities
so I think that that precursor really
sets up the idea that it's going to be a
a stakeholder process that will get all
the people in the room that need to be
uh in the
comments seeing none I'll ask the qu
clerk to call the role on the question
of ought to pass as amended with
Doug Thomas yes Janine nter yes Michael
Harrington yes stevenh Kennedy yes John
licki yes Lex bery yes JD bernardy yes
Tom PL yes James Summers yes C McGee
yes Rebecca McWilliams yes Jackie crean
yes Lucius parall
yes Tony Kaplan yes Chris muns yes Henry
Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Corman
yes Angela Brennan yes chairman Bose yes
nothing St adopts House Bill 558 FN as
ought to pass as amended by Amendment
H without objection I think we could put
calendar hearing no
objection that will be so
moved
and representative Thomas will write the
committee report for House Bill 558 FN
and with that we'll close the exact
session on HB
558 and open an ex exec session on House
Bill 609
FN and I will move ought to pass as
amended by Amendment 2023
2368 H and I'll recognize representative
McGee and I will second that motion it's
moved and seconded that we
judge House Bill
609- FN as worthy of ought to pass as
amended by Amendment
2368 H and I will speak to the motion
that I made to adopt this
amendment our subcommittee met three
times to discuss the changes that are in
the
amendment that you are looking at right
68h it makes significant several
significant changes to the site
evaluation committee it reduces the
number of the members of the committee
from nine to
five it sets those five members as three
members of the Pu the commissioner of
the Department of Environmental Services
and a public member who is appointed by
the governor and approved by the
council
it sets a quorum for the meetings of the
site evaluation committee at three
people unless those three people are the
public utilities Commissioners they
alone cannot constitute a quorum
according to the language on line 20 of
the
amendment the commissioner of the
Department of Environmental Services
Andor the public me member would be
required to join two other people to
constitute a
quorum the committee also uh the
chairperson of the committee who will be
the chair of the Public Utilities
Commission can delegate to other members
the duties of pres presiding officer on
a caseby Case
basis including the administrative
actions of the committee to that
presiding
officer another big change that the
amendment makes is to change the
definition of the site evaluation
committee
administrator this amendment makes that
person a employee of the Public
Utilities Commission who can float
between doing duties for the Public
Utilities Commission or the site
evaluation committee with
a preference for site evaluation
committee duties or a priority for site
site evaluation committee
duties and whenever
the administrator performs duties for
the
SEC they will be funded as set forth in
162 that basically follows the model
that the administrator is paid by today
this will relieve a lot of the funding
pressure that currently exists on the
site evaluation committee they have a
full-time administrator but they don't
have a way to pay
him by being an admin an employee of the
Public Utilities Commission that person
will get a regular paycheck and I'm sure
he will he or she will appreciate
that the other changes that the uh
amendment makes are basically language
Chang es to add designated presiding
officer to existing language in the
statute and the statute also because it
repeals the need for
subcommittees it makes some language
changes on page four lines 24
through uh 30 to remove the mention of a
subcommittee
in on page
four starting at line 32 the funding
plan there was a reference on page five
actually line three to a section of the
law that no longer exists so that had to
be removed as well so those are the
changes that this amendment
makes After extensive discussion with
the
subcommittee we believe that these
changes will significantly
improve the
timeliness of the site evaluations
committee's deliberations and its
processing
of the applications that are made for a
site certificate we also believe that it
will reduce the cost of those
applications by improving the
timeline and getting those applications
dealt with more
promptly so we think this is a good
Amendment as written as you can see the
amendment is sponsored by all five
members of our subcommittee we recommend
its uh
adoption and I'd like to hear
your discussion of this amendment we'll
start with representative Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair um 609 as we first
got it had a fiscal note and you just
mentioned that this amendment will
include the funding of a position so
does that mean the fiscal note will be
this if we adopt this uh Amendment and
the bill moves forward the fiscal note
will be revised yes and do you have an
idea of the cost I I mean I'm not the
the cost to fund that position do you
have an idea of how much that would that
would
be I can't answer that no okay thank you
further discussion representative
Harrington yeah um but just I caution
people on this uh let's not uh give up
the good to find the perfect uh I think
I'm the only one that's actually served
on a site evaluation committee and I
served on seven or eight of them and
they're a mess they go on and on and on
hours of trying to schedule things get
people together they stretch out for
months upon months upon months and it
sends a message to people don't come to
New Hampshire because it's too confusing
and too complicated to invest here so
this is a big step in the right
direction it may not be perfect we may
be back here or someone back here two or
three years from now saying well we've
been using this but we can make some
more tweaks to make it better that's
probably going to happen but again let's
not hold off for perfect when we have
good and this is a good step in the
right
direction thank you I think it's
important to point out that this
amendment to the site evaluation
committee
process while it makes some changes the
vast majority of the existing process
continues to exist and will move forward
it will be the process by which site
certificates are evaluated by which the
public will participate in the sighting
process so it's important to keep that
in mind that while these in changes are
important the vast majority of RSA 162
remains in effect now we already
modified part of RSA 162 with hb281
back earlier this year and those
amendments are now part of existing
statute those were important amendments
because they clar clarified the role of
state agencies in this
process that has been done and this
amendment continues the process of
reforming the site evaluation Committee
in such a way as to make it more
effective representative Thomas has a
comment thank you Mr chair uh actually
just like what you said I just wanted to
add that this is a prime example of a
bill that had an extremely Lively public
hearing when it was first uh brought up
and the work efforts on both sides of
the parties has resulted in significant
progress in small steps but significant
nonetheless and I think this is an
excellent example of how the hard work
that was done between both both sides in
getting something actually done that
will actually improve the process
representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman I just want to repeat something
I said in our subcommittee meeting which
is uh something that doesn't happen very
often I agree with the remarks from
representative
Harrington and the Patriots still lost
Ms representative Ms you're recognized
thank thank you Mr chair as I as a said
a few minutes ago um word words do
matter and um I I think this is an
exceptionally well-written
Amendment um so um no no no objections
there and I and I also believe that it
will
um um help to expedite the review and
approval of um you know much needed uh
projects going forward so I U I commend
the uh study
committee representative Summers
thank you Mr chair U my only question is
narrowing down from nine down to five
and accept in the case of where there's
only one commissioner from the Pu
present to make Quorum was it the
intention to have a uh majority number
else not sure I understand the question
but so to verify if if there's four
members and you have two two PU and one
of each of the other the Pu outnumbers
them if there's three members and two of
them are pu so all all the cases except
for the case where there's only one pu
member the Pu would always outnumber the
other members in that quum of five if is
it was that the intention that's was
asking yeah I think the answer is yes
yes representative n thank you Mr
chairman I had a question for you when
the subcommittee Met uh were members of
the public present at the sub committee
that were here for the original Bill yes
all of the subc commmittee members were
noticed in the calendar and were open
public meetings held in this room in
fact followup followup uh there we in my
notes uh there was one woman who was
adamantly opposed to this bill because
she doesn't like wind um does this
amendment satisfy her name is Lisa Leno
h i I know you know her I'm not sure how
to say her name Leno Lisa Len did not
attend any of the subcommittee
meetings thank you representative Wendy
Thomas thank you Mr chair um just
clarification
um I'm getting some concern from people
about uh lines 13 and 16 where it moves
from committee to chairperson or
designated presiding officer the concern
is is is and it might be legitimate or
not that that chairperson now has to
much Authority and is almost in a
concern I don't believe it is no one
ever raised that issue in the
subcommittee meetings that we had that
we had we heard from members of the doe
we heard from members of the Public
Utilities Commission we heard from
various other parties and that that
issue was never raised should it have
been should it have
been not to my not to my understanding
no fair enough thank
you representative Harrington yeah just
to be clear on this the the being the
chair of the committee is just an
administrative function only they get
one vote just like everybody else so
there's nothing you don't have any extra
power it simply mean someone has to set
up the scheduling and all the other
stuff and that's what themselves
responsible for so they they can't hold
back a vote or anything like that I
representative Thomas Wendy Thomas
please um don't speak unless you're
called on by the chair I I in my
experience there's always been a chair
and there's never been a situation where
the chair stood up and say we're not
going to vote on this and we're not
going to do that because the rest of the
committee could simply say well we are
and they' have if they have the votes
they can get it
done do you need to make a further
comment now no I'm all set thank you
okay thank
you representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman I just wanted to mention that
in those hearings um the amendment that
we were considering when we first uh
started the hearings had uh a different
person than the head of the Pu as the
chair of the SEC and so the amendment
that we were considering which I favored
uh said that the um the appointed
attorney on the Public Utilities
Commission would be the chair of the SEC
and then there were several people who
came up to testify saying that that
might not be administratively
a good a good thing but um many of the
people who I think proposed that and
myself included I didn't propose it but
I agreed that I thought that that
separation of of um of leadership would
have been a good thing so to your
question we did discuss it um there was
some opposition to it but it didn't
question well seeing none it looks like
we're ready to vote on the question of
UT to pass as amended by Amendment 2368
h of House Bill 609 Mr clerk please call
call the role Doug Thomas yes jine nder
yes Michael Harrington yes Steven
Kennedy yes John leeki yes Lex Bry yes
jie Bernardi yes Tom PL yes James
Summers yes cat McGee yes Rebecca
McWilliams yes Jackie cran yes Lucius
parshall yes Tony Kaplan yes Chris muns
yes Henry Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Corman yes Angela Brennan yes
20 okay bye a vote of 20 to zero the
committee
adopts HB 609 as ought to pass as
amended with Amendment
H and while it would be tempting to put
this on the consent calendar I think it
would probably be pulled off by someone
so this will go on the regular calendar
and I will write the committee report
for HB
609 with that we'll close the public
hearing on House Bill b or the um
executive session rather on House Bill
609 and we'll open a exec session on
House Bill
616 and I will
recognize representative Harrington for
a motion yeah I move to
itl representative Summers I second that
motion it's moved and seconded that we
itl HB
616 representative Harrington do you
want to speak to your motion yeah very
very briefly we just inter studied uh
509 which deals with the same issue so
there's really no sense in having two
bills floating around and whatever
issues are uh in this could be uh taken
up if and when we decide to do something
with 509 so this this bill is not
discussion seeing none I guess we can
vote on the question of itl on House
Bill 616
FN Mr clerk are you ready yes please
call the role Doug Thomas yes Janine ner
yes Michael Harrington yes stevenh
Kennedy yes John licki yes Lex bney yes
JD bernardy yes Tom PL yes James Summers
yes kamige yes Rebecca mcwells yes
Jackie cran yes Lucius par
yes Tony Kaplan yes Chris muns yes Henry
Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Corman
yes Angela Brennan yes chairman o yes 20
Z by a vote of 20 to zero the committee
adopts the recommendation of itl on
House Bill
616-
FN without objection I think this can go
hearing no
objection so moved this bill will go on
consent and representative Harrington
will write the committee
report and with that we'll close the
exec session on HB
616 and open an exec session on House
Bill
FN and I will move ought to pass as
amended and offer Amendment
2292 H and I'll recognize representative
McGee I'll second that motion it's moved
and seconded that we judge HB 622 to be
worthy of ought to pass as amended by
Amendment
2292 H and I will speak to that
so when we were having the committee
discussions on House Bill 2
281 this past
spring it was suggested that if the easy
board was repealed the statute covering
the easy board was repealed that it
might be wor worthwhile
to try to capture some of
[Music]
the knowledge and some of the uh
institutional knowledge
and other expertise of the people who
were on the energy board in another
fashion and it was suggested that the
grid modernization Advisory Group which
had just been uh passed in an earlier
bill I think it was Senate Bill 166
might be a good place for um that to
happen so this bill or this amendment
rather creates within the grid
modernization Advisory Group the
additional
responsibility of exploring methods of
modernizing streamlining and finding
efficiencies in the delivery of Energy
Efficiency programs and incentives with
a goal of maximizing the consumer
benefit of existing state federal and
utility funding
streams that's what the amendment does
it changes the bill completely changes
the title
from its previous title of relative to
administration of the New Hampshire
renewable no repealing Energy Efficiency
and sustainable energy board to relative
to the grid modernization Advisory Group
comments seeing none I guess we're ready
to vote if you're ready Mr clerk please
call the rooll on the motion of
otpa with Amendment 2292 H Doug Thomas
yes Janine ner yes Michael Harrington
yes Steven Kennedy yes John lewicki yes
Lex bery yes jie bernardy yes Tom PL yes
James Summers yes cat McGee yes Rebecca
McWilliams yes Jackie crean yes Lucius
parshall yes Tony Kaplan yes Chris muns
yes Henry Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Corman yes Angela Brandon yes
20 okay the committee adopts House Bill
622 FN as amended
by Amendment 2292 H by a vote of 20 to
nothing and this bill I think
also might benefit from being placed on
the consent calendar is there any
objection
seeing
none it'll go on the consent calendar
it's it's as an FN so it may need to go
there right can't go consent got to go
to fiscal first well that was the
original
bill that's true I'm not sure that the
amended bill needs to be FN I will
consult with the clerk and if the clerk
gives us permission we'll put it on the
and uh I will write the committee report
for this
legislation and with that we'll close
that executive session and now we're
down to our final executive session of
the day we've done remarkable work here
so far this morning so let's keep let's
keep it keep the role
going I'll open the exec session on
House Bill 6
631 FN and I'll call on representative
Thomas for a motion thank you Mr chair
uh motion on hb631 is
itl representative bernardy I second the
motion it's moved and seconded that we
judge House Bill 631 to be worthy of
itl Representative Thomas do you want to
comment on your motion yes Mr chair
thank you
um on the surface this bill would look
like it's okay cuz it's just a uh an
enabling bill it gives people options
but when you look at the bill talks
about smart meters and it doesn't again
we've had this discussion over the last
several many years doesn't really Define
what a smart meter is and then in
addition we learned that uh in order for
a smart meter to work the way that
people would like to work there are
additional um software and items that
need to be put behind it which which
don't exist right now and the utilities
especially eversource is not set up to
provide that in that uh that that type
of
support uh so we're looking at a bill
that would enable someone to get a smart
meter if they want but if they get it
they really can't use it because there's
nothing behind it to support it and
there are very many analogies that are
being made it's uh my analogy is like uh
you know selling someone 8K TV when you
only have 4K broadcasting capability
it's really not much of use and there
are other analogies out there that that
can be used the same way so this bill
really doesn't add anything uh to the
state of New Hampshire and in my opinion
it's uh just a useless bill so for that
it further discussion representative
McGee I I I didn't know if Dr crean
wanted to speak no she doesn't okay so
um this was really you know a priority
bill in that we were looking for a way
to uh help folks get on the early
adoption
bandwagon um and even fast follower
bandwagon uh with technology in a way
that was not mandated and so um the idea
that the bill is uh not specific enough
in terms of identifying what type of
smart meter Gateway devices would be
appropriate we are leaving like we often
do to the utilities who actually
understand uh what the landscape is out
there with these devices to the point
that if the utilities are not currently
set up to read those devices that it
would uh not be a useful thing for
individuals to be able to adopt them
that is not what we have heard from
people who are already using smart uh
meter Gateway devices so there is a way
way there is a potential for if this
bill were passed we would be telling the
utilities that they need to accommodate
this and then we would find that those
Solutions do exist there are people that
are using them already they use them
with software applications that they can
download on their phone so they don't
need the utility to be able to help them
read that information and use that
information to do Energy Efficiency so I
I will not be voting to itl this bill I
will um still be looking OTP which is
what we had sort of discussed early on I
understand the points that are being
brought up but I don't think they're um
they're sufficient to kill this bill and
make us delay
further representative
Berney
um I guess the the issue or the question
I would have is so this isn't about
smart meter it's about Gateway devices
specifically um which which is the
device that goes after the smart meter
or connects to the smart meter and
allows the utility to control devices in
the home but if the utility doesn't have
a way to talk to that device or doesn't
have any software it's not very useful
uh but even if like you said if if a
person has software themselves that they
run to control the device the device
would still need information from the
utility like either if this if there's a
demand currently or um or what the price
is of electricity right now but the
utility doesn't do Dynamic pricing or
Real Time pricing so there's no there's
no way to respond to the current price
to to either turn things off or turn
them on um so I guess I'm not really
sure you said that there are users who
are using this can you give an example
of something that somebody's done with a
Gateway device in New Hampshire with a
utility that was beneficial sure I I
guess you know eversource is is kind of
an outlier they're they're the largest
electricity supplier but they're not the
only electricity supplier and the New
Hampshire co-op has had their customers
on meters with Gateway devices um and
and I believe Unitil also uh has
advanced metering and the capability to
provide people with additional
information there's also um a pending
docket at the Pu to approve the building
of the the data Hub or the Statewide
energy data platform which would allow
people to access uh utility data uh slic
different ways and they wouldn't have to
get it necessarily through the utilities
directly so what this is doing is trying
to able technologies that will help us
get further down the road uh without
like I said further delay um people are
not going to buy these devices unless
they have a way that they want to use
them I would imagine that even the
community power Coalition is also uh
hoping that folks will advance the
technology so that they can have
something to tie
into and help people with monitoring
their
energy further representative
Berne yeah I just so I think I remember
during dur during the hearings for this
bill I think it was somebody from
eversource they mentioned that if if
this were to pass they would have to
spend money to re to Resource you know
figuring out which devices they're going
to use and then Provide support and make
sure that they can you know get enough
of those devices um and that that
doesn't seem to make sense if they don't
offer the service you know other other
utilities might offer the service and it
makes sense for them to S device but if
a utility doesn't offer the service of
talking to the device what would be the
point of having them spend money and
procure these devices to offer them to
customers if there's no um if they don't
intend to or or don't currently offer
the
service representative McGee thanks um
it's a good question um and my
understanding is that that eversource
does have plans to eventually move
towards smarter meters than they have
now that
infrastructure uh effort is a number of
years away
um but at this point if folks were able
to invest in their own individual
devices towards that effort they would
have to make a decision around what
would be a standard that they could
settle on so that it would accommodate
that future technology that's kind of
what we're asking them to do with the
bill is to say you're not thinking about
this now but we want you to be thinking
about this now so that people can have
the option and they could certainly pass
through saying these are the these are
the meters that we advise you to have
they don't have to have them in stock
uh they just have to make sure that
people know what they should be
buying representative Harrington did I
see your hand up
no uh representative
crean thank you chair um I just wanted
to add my understanding is also that
eversource um in the other states where
it operates does offer these devices and
it sort of just dragging its feet in New
Hampshire because it can um so I don't
think it would be the worst thing in the
world to push them a little bit here
representative
bernardy thank you Mr chair uh if if
ever source is going to make a move to
offer the this uh uh ability to connect
uh and provide this service then this
bill is not necessary we've had Unitil
and we've had uh the power Cooperative
others
put this service and capability out
there they didn't require any
legislation to do it I don't believe we
need to legislate in this area either we
let the market just move forward on its
own further discussion representative
parshall thank you
chair I think what we have here is
somewhat of a trying to Define which one
is the cart and which one's the horse uh
Smart
Meters as a means to getting us to uh
demand pricing is something that I see
is very necessary and I see demand
pricing is also something we need is
really try to flatten the curve that we
have and try to reduce demand so we
don't have all these power generators
always running in response what might be
a peak demand we need to flatten this
curve we need to minimize resources and
by offering demand pricing we'll get
there now which one comes first the
smart meter or the uh decision that
we're going to develop these
software I don't
have the ability to demand that ever
Source Begins the later process but this
is something we can put in right now
saying that we can frontload this by
supporting this bill so I'll be voting
to support this bill thank
you representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman uh just to to follow up on
representer Bernard's comment about
letting the market uh settle this
utility customers don't get to choose
their utility except if they move so you
know if I'm an eversource customer and I
want eversource to or and I want a smart
meter Gateway device and ever Source
isn't providing one the only way I can
get one is to move
further discussion representative bney
yeah I'll just make one last comment so
if ever source for example takes another
three years to roll out the support for
this and you buy a device this year Well
three years from now your device is
probably going to be outdated and
there's probably a better one to buy so
it makes sense that you buy the device
offered further discussion
representative
Bernardi so to follow up on uh
representative corman's comment the if
the customer base is interested in this
and presents their views to eversource
that will drive this we do not need to
do this by
legislation representative Wendy Thomas
um however if there's no incentive um
for the uh utilities to develop this um
capability because it will cost money
and they're not big on that
uh you know I see this bill as just
lighting a fire under the utilities and
saying you know build it now and they
will
come further discussion representative
Doug Thomas uh thank you Mr chair
um the issue I have with this bill is
that there it appears to be a a a
presumption that naturally we want to go
to demand pricing and I don't think the
state has made that policy yet nor would
I support that per se so I I think I
would uh in in in in difference to the
the comments on technology I would have
to agree with representative BR that you
someone can go out and buy something now
that's not usable now but might be
usable in five years it's going to find
out that whatever they bought is
probably go is probably going to be OB
obsolete I don't think we should be in
my opinion I don't think we should be
trying to incentivize an idea that has
not yet been adopted uh by the state
with a bill that would uh perhaps
artificially give people the impression
that we are going to do this and they'll
go out and buy something on their own to
find out that it's it's not being used
yet we need to wait until you know
policy is set and that we till we figure
out what we are going to do what makes
sense to do and that's the primary
bill uh thank you Mr chairman well in my
opinion under the present regime where
you can separate your energy electricity
cost from the Transportation cost then
this would require uh coordination
between your supplier as opposed to your
uh um uh Transportation co uh provider
uh because clearly if you're buying your
electricity from Joe independent
electricity company then that's the one
you'd have to coordinate with to do
utility representative
Kennedy uh yeah just a newbie couple
newbie questions one one I I understood
that eversource is the company that
manages the grid period they buy
electricity from lots of other people
but um if you wanted something like a
smart meter to work I mean wouldn't they
have to do it it the the second question
I see people saying no so maybe that's
not true the second question is when you
had discussions on this bill did
opinion so the answer to your first
question is ever source is the biggest
utility in the state but they don't
manage the grid no one utility does the
answer to your second question is did
they testify yes they did and they were
opposed to this bill at when they
testified
further
discussion representative
Summers I guess my biggest question I'm
kind of relaying off of what kind of
what JD said earlier was is without this
legislation we've had multiple utilities
be able to enable and apply smart
metering devices to folks homes and they
were able to do that without any
legislation whatsoever and from my
understanding is this bill basically
pointing to one utility and so the we're
asking the state to tell this one
utility what to do and is that the only
bill representative mck
Williams thank you chair um I just
wanted to point out two really important
things first uh we're in a captive
market and so the decisions that we the
members of st& make actually do have an
impact on the market and that's part of
our job as elected representatives to
make Market changes so that certainly is
something that's underlying the entire
discussion about this bill is do we want
to force one of the players in the
market to make a change uh the second
piece I think is just as important um
what we're talking about is people who
are on the cutting or potentially even
bleeding edge okay so when we talk risk
reward the people who are taking a risk
with this bill are individual citizens
of New Hampshire who are deciding they
want to spend their own money and get a
smart Dev advice and they want to find
out what that means and perhaps even
change their behavior that's their risk
and so they take that risk for the next
three or 5 years and Technology can
change and it be becomes Obsolete and we
all know that's just the way of the
world but nonetheless the risk is on the
individual purchaser we're not forcing
anything we're not increasing costs
we're not spreading this out across
other people and saying oh we want to
support this effort by making everyone
pay more so some people can get smart
devices that's not what we're doing
we're asking for a recommendation
specific from ever source for what smart
meter device they think people should
purchase if and when they take their own
risk and make that purchase and for that
reason I absolutely support this bill
because we should be pushing the market
thank
you representative
Kaplan yeah I I'm sorry I can't support
this legislation and uh the reason for
that is I think it's wrong-headed uh I
just think it's not our job to
micromanage utilities and tell them what
products they need to be offering their
their customers I think if we want to
change the market that's what our job is
as a legislature and that is to change
the way the market functions and I'm a
strong believer that demand side
response is an important component in
saving people's money and lowering the
uh the climate implications of the way
we use energy so if we want demand side
to be a part of the way the market
functions that's our job as a
legislature is to set that up so that's
that's how it functions not by telling
utilities to offer a certain product to
a particular class of customers and
putting all the weight of changing the
way the energy system functions on a
group of pioneering customers who are
going to you know change the world
work representative
Harrington yeah I guess maybe I'm a
little confused at what the bill is
trying to accomplish it talks about
putting in smart meat is undefined
exactly what that that that is and
whether is any software that has to be
required with that and how it's used but
as long as we don't don't have time of
day rates if you're paying whatever it
is let's just make it up 20 cents a
kilowatt hour 247 all the time uh having
a smart meter I'm not sure what it's
doing for you because you're are going
to get your power delivered that way and
you're not going to be paying a variable
rate with time I don't know of any uh
supplier now that says we'll I mean
there's some very large industrial
suppliers that go into the market
themselves and they do buy time of day
and the studies I've indicate shows that
that's there's a significant savings
there but we're talking about large
industrial users here for residential
homeowner they'll have a smart meeter
what is it going to do for them because
they're going to pay the same price of
power whether it's 12:00 noon or 12
midnight or whatever so I'm just not
sure what this
accomplishes further discussion
representative ner thank you Mr chairman
um since we have Representatives on the
committee that
um what are would like to um tell
eversource what to do would it be
appropriate at this time to ask the
eversource representative or lobbyist to
come to the mic to give us a refresher
but is there any further
discussion representative bney thank you
Mr chairman I guess uh I have a question
so if if the purpose of this is to
encourage eversource to to at some point
provide the um real-time pricing or to
provide software that will then talk to
the Gateway device wouldn't it make
sense to legislate then requiring to do
that as opposed to requiring them to
offer a device that doesn't
work good question representative crean
um I believe the problem with that is
the chicken and egg that we were talking
about before so if we ask them to do
that then they'll say well we can't
possibly do that because people don't
have Smart Meters um so this is just
again a way to allow people to express
they want this information they want to
be able to engage in this pricing and
hopefully encourage ever source to be
responsive to
that all right we seem to be going back
and forth back and forth here unless
there's a a real uh pressing need I see
no need for further discussion I think
we should just take a vote and see uh
let the chips fall May where they may
and any objection to
that representative n just one more
point that I don't think anybody said is
anytime we ask like if we ask ever
source to tell them that they have to
spend this money to recoup their cost we
all have to pay for it it's just going
to raise our
rates good point okay representative
McGee did you have a final Point yeah I
mean the whole point of the bill is that
it's the individuals who would spend the
money if they want to have a smarter
meter than what they have today it isn't
on all the rate payers to do that if
there are peripheral costs you know that
could that's something that we could
assess but that is not the idea of this
bill the idea of this bill is that
people who want Smart Meters would be
able to invest in the technology and
then there would be less of a expense
for all rate payers at the time when
eversource decides to transition us over
so the because the infrastructure would
already be partially
upgraded okay I think uh We've exhausted
the discussion topics on this bill so
I'd like to see us vote so I'm going to
ask the clerk to call the role on the
631 Doug
Thomas yes Janine ner yes Michael
Harrington
yes Steven Kennedy yes John liwicki yes
Lex pery yes JD bernardy yes Tom PL yes
James Su uh yeah James Summers yes cat
McGee no Rebecca McWilliams no Jackie
crean no Lucius parel no Tony Kaplan
yes Chris muns
no Henry Noel
no uh Wendy Thomas no Thomas Corman no
Angela Brennan no
chairman Vos
yes okay 10 11 one two three four five
six seven eight nine 11 to
nine by a vote of 11 to nine the motion
of itl is
adopted and
representative Thomas will write the
committee
report on this uh on this bill House
and with that I think we can uh close
the exec session
on yes representative
Ms will there be a Minority
Report good question does the minority
wish to issue a
report representative McGee
yes and who will write that report
representative
McGee uh Dr crean all right there will
be a minority report written by
representative cren all right with that
we'll close the exec session on House
Bill
631 and now I'll ask the committee if
there is any other business that they
would like to address while we're here
today
because after we leave here today we
won't be reconvening until after the 1
of January so is there any other
representative Wendy Thomas just like to
say happy holidays to everybody and
enjoy the time with your
families thank you for that good wish
and I would hope everybody would share
it representative cren um just wanted to
take the chance to thank everybody who
worked on all this legislation in the
interim especially 609 coming to a
resolution on that Big Bill appreciate
it thanks representative Harrington yeah
representative Corman and myself are
going to have to get together and find
something to agree on a lot because
otherwise the Patriots are going to lose
every
game although you guys don't know if
that strategy works because it worked
once but it didn't work the other
time take 50% it's worth a try it's
worth a try they need all the help they
can get representative Corman thank you
uh I just wanted to recognize uh your
work Mr chairman on HB 609 uh chairing
the sub committee meeting three times
taking input and being so receptive to
input and coming up with a a really very
good resolution so thank you for your
work well thank you and thanks to the
members of the subcommittee who worked
very very hard and
diligently to uh put together the the
final version of that Amendment and I
think uh I really look forward to moving
it to the Senate and seeing uh if we can
get uh get it to the finish line and
have the governor sign it I think the
governor would be in full support of
it so with that I guess we're done for
the day thanks to everybody for being
here this morning good work uh we'll see
year